[Musica]
fin da quando ero piccolo sono sempre
stato
ho sempre apprezzato la bellezza che si
può osservare in natura in particolare
sono sempre stato affascinato dalle
forme i colori che si possono osservare
attraverso gli insetti in particolare i
coleotteri
io sono di como e passavo tutti le mie
stati a cercare di prendere questi cervi
volanti quelli in mezzo che erano
fantastici quando volano ce ne sono
sempre di meno in cui intorno e son
finito a lavorare in california con un
altro insetto uno che senz'altro voi
adorate anche la zanzara quello delle
zanzare è un problema enorme perché ogni
anno causano quasi un milione di morti
sulla terra tra tutti gli animali sono i
più mortali e ci lasciano al secondo
posto nella classifica dei killer
le zanzare di persone innocue sono ci
danno noia sono sono fastidiose però
sono innocue
il problema è che sono vettori di
parassiti e virus che causano malattie
molto debilitanti e in molti casi anche
mortali
la peggiore di queste malattie al
momento è la malaria la malaria è
causata da un parassita che si chiama
plasmodium e queste zanzare non sono
nate con il plasmodio devono pungere
qualcuno che ha infettato per poi
trasmettere una persona non infetta ed è
così che la malaria si trasmette da una
persona all'altra questo plasmodium è un
parassita intracellulare una volta che è
entrato nel nostro flusso sanguigno si
entra nei nostri globuli rossi si
riproduce all'interno e se li mangia uno
alla volta ed è questo che causa la
malaria è portata da zanzare come
abbiamo detto ma non tutte le zanzare
possono portare il plasmodium
per esempio la zanzara tigre che
senz'altro avete sentito non può portare
la malaria solamente un piccolo gruppo
di zanzare anofele del genius anofele
possono portare la malaria in più questo
plasmodium è specifico per gli uomini
questo vuol dire che non può essere
trasmesso dagli animali o agli animali e
in più non può sopravvivere in una
palude in una foresta è un partito
obbligato vuol dire che rimane
all'interno dell'uomo e della zanzara e
questo ci dà un vantaggio perché
potremmo in teoria rompere completamente
questo ciclo esso ciclo di vita che è
completato completamente dentro la
zanzara è l'uomo con medicine ai
pesticidi potremmo rompere il ciclo e se
potessimo farlo istantaneamente su tutta
la faccia della terra
potremmo debellare la malattia il
problema è che non è così facile
applicare queste medicine e pesticidi
ovunque e la malaria rimane endemica in
un sacco di paesi specialmente paesi più
poveri ed è ancora un enorme problema
specialmente in africa nel centro sud
africa dove causa la morte di migliaia
di bambini le persone più afflitte sono
bambini sotto i 5 anni la malaria si è
il plasmodium si è evoluto con gli
uomini quindi è stato con noi da
millenni e negli ultimi 150 anni
abbiamo iniziato a combattere le zanzare
e il plasmodium con tutti i mezzi che
riuscivamo a trovare
abbiamo usato zanzariere per bloccare le
zanzare
abbiamo usato pesticidi li abbia messi
sulle zanzariere per cercare di
ucciderlo e abbiamo fumi gato intere
città con questi pesticidi cercando di
uccidere zanzare in più abbiamo
sviluppato medicine sia per prevenire
plasmodium che sto anche prendendo io
perché sono stato in india settimana
scorsa
oppure per curare persone che fossero
infette dal plasmodium tutti questi
metodi stanno lentamente fallendo dal
momento che li abbiamo usati per così
tanto tempo e molti esperti nel campo
medico scientifico stanno sono molto
preoccupati perché per esempio le
zanzare stanno sviluppando un nuovo
comportamento e hanno imparato a
pungerci alla sera fuori dalla casa
invece che dentro mentre sian dormendo
in più hanno sviluppato resistenza ai
pesticidi e alla stessa maniera il
plasmodium ha anche sviluppato la
resistenza alle medicine che usiamo e
questo è anche rispecchiato nei
nell'aumento di casa di malaria che si
può osservare negli ultimi due tre anni
ora non sono stato invitato qua da
gerolamo perché sono un esperto di
malaria ma perché sono esperto di
ingegneria genetica e prima di parlarvi
del nuovo strumento che stiamo
sviluppando in california per usando la
genetica per combattere la malaria
faccio un piccolo rinfresco di genetica
di base le zanzare esattamente come noi
hanno due copie del genoma uno che viene
dalla mamma è uno che viene dal papa e
se prendiamo una zanzara che è blu
perché ha un gene blu diciamo che venga
dalla mamma questo genere blu questo
gene blu una volta che la zanzara blu si
accoppia con una zanzara nera ha il 50
per cento delle probabilità di dare
questo gene blu alla sua progenie quindi
solamente la metà dei figli di questa
zanzara saranno anche loro blu e
generazione dopo generazione
questo gene blu rimane nella popolazione
con una certa frequenza seguendo le
leggi dell'eredità di mendel mentre io
stavo lavorando sul mio dottorato a san
diego
mi sono chiesto e se avessimo un gene
verde che invece potrebbe in qualche
modo convertire quel gene nero che viene
dall altro
il genitore ad essere anche lui verde
come questa eredità di mendel sarebbe
modificata la zanzara verde ora a due
copie di questo genere e se si accoppia
una zanzara nera non al 50 per cento di
probabilità di darlo ai figli ma tutti i
suoi figli avranno una copia di questo
gene verde in più dal momento che ha
questa capacità di accoppiarsi
sull'altro copia del genoma che viene
dall altro genitore generazione dopo
generazione la frequenza di questo gene
verde aumenterà nella popolazione fino a
che l'intera popolazione non avrà questo
gene verde questo tipo di eredità è
stato studiato da quasi cent'anni si
chiama gene drive ed occorre in natura
quindi ci sono diversi meccanismi che
possono generare un eredità aumentata
tipo tipo questa che stiamo cercando di
fare in california quello che noi
abbiamo fatto è generare un gene drive
che è completamente sintetico quindi
completamente il fatto in laboratorio
che può essere usato per modificare per
essere inserito in qualsiasi punto nel
genoma della zanzara abbiamo fatto così
usando una nuova tecnologia che è stata
sviluppata recentemente che si chiama
chris per sé i due componenti basi della
della tecnologia chris peris si chiamano
cas naim e khalid arene la cas nyen è
come se fosse un enzima ed è come se
fosse una forbice molecolare è fatta per
tagliare il dna mentre il guideline e è
come se fosse un indirizzo dice
esattamente alla cas nine dove tagliare
abbiamo preso un gene per la cas nine è
un gene per il gai dove nell e abbiamo
messo in mezzo a una sequenza di dna che
è esattamente uguale a quella del genoma
di una zanzara questo pezzo di dna
sintetico
circolare che si chiama plasmide è stato
iniettato dentro le uova delle zanzare e
funziona in questa maniera la qashqai
nel gridare né si uniscono il kite ne
dice esattamente dalla catena in dove
tagliare e tagliano il genoma ad una
certa posizione
a questo punto la cellula non posso per
vivere col dna rotte quindi si guarda in
giro trova una sequenza che è uguale e
la usa come temprato per correggere quel
taglio e quindi in questa maniera
riusciamo a inserire la cas nine il
gaither né esattamente a quella
posizione e così che abbiamo creato una
la prima zanzara transgenica con questo
metodo cosa succede subito dopo è che
l'altra copia del genoma quella che è il
gene nero con la stessa maniera adesso
viene tagliata sempre dalla cascina
energia né che adesso sono dentro nel
genoma della zanzara e viene copiata
nella stessa identica posizione
sull'altra copia del cromosoma
esattamente quel gene verde che volevamo
fare
ora voi direte non è che vogliamo fare
zanzare verdi o le zanzare blu gli
vogliamo dare una caratteristica che
possa aiutarci nella lotta contro le
zanzare e per questo io il mio mentore e
tanvir che stavamo lavorando su questo
gene drive
ci siamo messi in collaborazione con un
altro professore dell'università della
california di irvine
chi invece aveva sviluppato una seconda
cassetta genetica che rende le zanzare
immuni al plasmodio della malaria queste
zanzare ed i toni una volta che pongono
qualcuno che che al plasmodium non
possono trasmetterlo a una persona non
infetta
com'è che funzionano queste zanzare che
questo ricercatore ha generato
quando le zanzare si fanno una bella
bevuta di sangue e si mangiano anche
plasmodi nel frattempo questi plasmodi
devono uscire dallo stomaco entrare nel
sistema linfatico della zanzara queste
zanzare sono però modificate così che
producono degli anticorpi
tra l'altro sono anticorpi umani quindi
c'è una cassetta genetica nella zanzara
che produce anticorpi umani che bloccano
i plasmodium mentre stanno cercando di
uscire dallo stomaco
se anche uno di questi plasmodium riesce
a uscire nel sistema linfatico c'è un
secondo anticorpo che è lì pronto con
una tossina per ucciderlo prima che
riesca ad arrivare alle ghiandole
salivari dove deve arrivare per essere
trasmesso alla prossima persona quello
che abbiamo fatto e abbiamo combinato il
nostro gene drive sintetico con questa
nuova caratteristica abbiamo creato
queste zanzare queste zanzare anno in
teoria la capacita di modificare
l'intera popolazione del mondo delle
zanzare anofele ad essere completamente
immuni alla malaria e nel giro di un
anno potrebbero debellare la malaria
completamente ora come binetto prima la
realtà è sempre un po diversa e quindi
applica fare un'applicazione del genere
in tutto il mondo è molto complesso la
genetica delle zanzare e complessa e
anche quella dei partiti molto complessa
quindi questa tecnologia andrà a
supplementare l'uso di pesticidi e
medicine e vaccini che sono in sviluppo
alcuni di voi si saranno chiesti come
anche altre persone ma non è pericoloso
modificare un intero specie giusto non è
che può avere delle implicazioni
sull'ecosistema che non sono previste
queste sono senz'altro delle domande che
ci dobbiamo chiedere
quando facciamo l'applicazione di una
tecnologia così potente ma vorrei
mettere le cose un pochino in
prospettiva e comparare questo gene
drive a quello che stiamo usando
tutt'oggi per combattere gli insetti
unico sistema un sistema molto complesso
ci sono molti nodi e al momento
rovesciamo tonnellate e tonnellate di
pesticidi nell'ecosistema cercando di
uccidere questi insetti le zanzare sono
uno di quelli
altri sono bestia greek di agricoltura o
anche non so le formiche che ti entrano
in casa e ti danno fastidio le vuoi
uccidere e facendo così non va a colpire
solamente l'insetto che non ti piace vai
a colpire tutti gli insetti di un intero
ecosistema in più hai un un effetto
indiretto su piante animali che hanno
delle relazioni con questi insetti per
esempio animali che si mangiano in 7
quindi un gene drive non ha un effetto
del genere un gene drive è una cosa che
è squisitamente specifica per una sola
specie quindi un solo anello all'interno
di un ecosistema in p non è che lo
rimuoviamo gli diamo semplicemente una
caratteristica leggermente diversa così
che non possa portare il parassita che
ci annoia e con il riscaldamento
climatico e la globalizzazione queste in
7 si stanno muovendo di continente in
continente e ogni anno stanno sempre
venendo più a nord e portandosi con loro
sono anche queste malattie
la maglia in italia è una cosa che
accade molto sporadicamente ma
senz'altro avete sentito dalla paura che
ci siamo presi con la zecca un paio
d'anni fa e altre malattie come la
dengue la ciconia stanno diventando un
serio problema in tutto il mondo e
quindi io sono convinto che questo gene
rale sia un nuovo strumento a nostra
disposizione che possiamo potremo usare
per una lotta a sostenibile contro
queste malattie
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]